game of war took the world by storm in
2015 with a high-profile Superbowl
commercial featuring scantily clad
supermodel Kate Upton an advertising
gimmick for which developer machines
owned reportedly paid 40 million dollars
since then the online strategy game has
become one of the top-selling mobile
apps in history but what's really
happening behind the scenes here's what
you may not know about game of war fire
age celebrity faces after spending
millions on Kate Upton's eye-catching
commercial drawing Super Bowl xlix
machines owned went for a change of pace
and a change of face the next superstar
to appear in a game of war commercial
was none other than pop star Mariah
Carey time to be heroes guys the
dragon-slaying diva spent a total of two
seconds on screen but reportedly earned
a seven-figure paycheck to be fair it
was still more effort than she put into
a new year's performance zing
[Applause]
[Music]
of course parcels of cash was probably
to license rights for her song to hearer
which has played relentlessly during the
ad was it as effective as a Kate Upton
spots it's hard to say but 2015 was
definitely a Grand Slam the year for
game of war according to the numbers
cha-ching it's not easy for a free game
to bring in a cool million a day but it
helps if you build your entire business
model around getting players to buy
stuff inside the game and if there's one
thing game of war is good at its making
sure its players have a reason to drop
loads of cash on their virtual kingdoms
game of war is what's known as a
freemium game it's free to download and
play but if you really want to have a
chance in the game you need to pay for
the premium content with mobile apps we
now have the ability to make games that
are boring and stupid but if you pay for
incentives you're rewarded freemium the
Miam is Latin for not really in fact
game of war makes a point to push
premium deals at just about every
loading screen obviously not every
player or even most players will spend
money to get in game advantages but
there are enough who are willing to do
just that to make a game of war one of
the top grossing mobile apps of our time
it also helps that gamers are spending
way more than the average on this app
six times as much in fact according to
the stats whereas ordinary mobile gamers
spend about eighty 6.50 dollars to play
game of war fans are dropping an average
of five hundred and fifty dollars a year
mostly to rack up on those gold packages
that cost a whopping ninety nine point
ninety nine dollars a piece
a heaping heist game of war is so
addictive that one guy stole 1 million
dollars to pay for his playing habits
actually he stole 4.8 million dollars
but he spent 1 million dollars of his
lifted loot on game of war Californian
Kevin Coe reportedly spent 7 years from
2008 to 2015 embezzling funds as an
accountant for a company specializing in
construction equipment he used most of
the money for big-ticket items like cars
and sports seats your standard
embezzlement candy but somewhere along
the way he decided that a free mobile
game was worth 1 million dollars of his
hard stolen money there's no record of
exactly what he bought in the game but
really does it matter that precious
Gollum ring won't help him in prison
critical cuts for all the money game of
war is raking in 4 machines own it may
be one of the most hated games of the
past few years critics have pointed out
as practically non-existent gameplay the
massive wait times to do anything useful
and the circular nature of the entire
system you basically build things so you
can build more things in the future but
more than anything most critics call out
game of war is nothing more than a
shameless cash-grab basically if you
aren't a big spender you can spend
months building your kingdom just to be
slaughtered by a newcomer with deep
pockets but for all that hate from on
high game of war must be doing something
right on top of raking in more cash than
some country's entire gross domestic
products game of war also garnered a
respectable rating on the Google Play
Store from us million-plus reviewers as
much as critics seem to love hating it
you can't argue with the numbers with
over 50 million downloads at this point
game of war is definitely popular but
how popular is it really well it's still
not top dog in spite of the tens of
millions of dollars machines owner spent
to reach the top game of war is still
only ranked 4th in the top grossing
iPhone games behind candy crush saga
Pokemon go and clash royale and that's
pretty far behind - if you go by the
numbers although game of war poured in
over 1 million dollars a day in 2015
their daily revenue has dropped to 720
thousand dollars while clash Royale is
currently raking in over two million
dollars each day holy hell
real-world impact while machines owned
started out as a game developer the
company's CEO Gabriel Adan has always
had bigger plans
he told Bloomberg that machines owned is
more than just a few hundred guys
building a popular mobile app saying
we're a technology company we're not
really a game company he certainly seems
to be on the right track the company
rebranded itself as simply MZ in April
of 2016 and in May 2016 they signed a
contract with the New Zealand government
to use game of wars technology to
improve the country's public
transportation using the system the game
incorporates to simultaneously keep
track of millions of players the Dunn's
real-world system will track and manage
the network structure for an entire city
soon the entire entire cities will be
networked in one real-time environment
which will create a level of efficiency
that the world hasn't seen yet is that
some Bishan savvy or just plain scary
you be the judge thanks for watching
click the loop icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know your love to
[Music]
[Applause]